[Music]
welcome back to Modern agry machines in
today's episode we explore how Cutting
Edge harvesting machines are
revolutionizing the world of Agriculture
from wheat to grapes Modern Machinery
has taken farming to the next level
boosting efficiency and productivity
like never before let's dive into the
details of how different machines are
transforming farming practices worldwide
[Music]
wheat has been a staple crop for
centuries wheat Harvesters have
revolutionize the way wheat is grown and
harvested creating a massive shift in
global
agriculture before Machinery Farmers had
to manually reap thresh and clean wheat
a process that required significant Time
and Labor however the introduction of
the combine harvester a machine capable
of Performing all three tasks
drastically reduced both time effort
modern wheed Harvesters not only improve
productivity but also help farmers
optimize their Harvest by gathering
crops quickly before weather changes can
damage them these machines are equipped
with advanced technology allowing them
to operate continuously over long
periods helping Farmers worldwide
Harvest millions of tons of wheat
annually additionally wheat Harvesters
minimize losses during the harvesting
process ensuring both the quality and
quantity of the crop this contributes to
increased food supply lower production
costs and the ability to meet Global
Food demands the wheat Harvester is
truly a major advancement enhancing
efficiency and supporting sustainable
growth in agriculture
[Music]
worldwide corn harvesting machines have
truly revolutionized Global agriculture
bringing unprecedented efficiency and
productivity compared to traditional
harvesting methods before the Advent of
modern machinery harvesting corn
required significant labor and time from
Farmers however with the introduction of
advanced corn Harvesters this task has
become much simpler and faster grain
corn Harvesters are designed to quickly
gather corn cobs and separate the
kernels right in the field this saves
time and labor while boosting
productivity
[Music]
for sweet corn specialized machines are
used to gently harvest the ears without
damaging the product ensuring the
highest quality for consumption
[Music]
as for silage corn corn biomass silage
Harvesters are employed to harvest the
entire corn plant for use as animal feed
maximizing the utilization of biomass
resources these corn harvesting machines
not only improve production efficiency
but also help farmers reduce labor costs
optimize the production process and
protect the environment by minimizing
emissions through the use of modern
machinery by enhancing these aspects of
Agriculture corn Harvesters are playing
a key role in transforming the industry
and shaping the future of farming
[Music]
[Applause]
potato and carrot Harvesters are two of
the most significant agricultural
technological advancements that have
revolutionized Global farming these
modern machines not only increase
harvesting efficiency but also reduce
labor costs and optimized crop yields
before the Advent of potato Harvesters
harvesting potatoes was an incredibly
labor intensive task Farmers had to
manually dig the soil and collect each
potato a process that was not only slow
but also led to significant losses in
productivity however with the
development of potato Harvesters this
process has been fully automated modern
potato Harvesters operate with high
efficiency capable of digging up and
collecting thousands of potatoes in a
short time The Machine's blade and
Conveyor Systems help separate the soil
and precisely gather the potatoes
without causing damage some machines
even feature cleaning and sorting
systems on the field saving time and
effort these Innovations have
significantly increased productivity and
reduced labor costs the machines also
help protect the soil through
scientifically designed digging
processes preventing erosion and soil
damage
[Music]
the carrot Harvester has also brought
about major changes to Global
agriculture previously harvesting
carrots required meticulous care as the
carrots are deeply rooted in the soil
and can easily break if not handled
properly modern carrot Harvesters have
fully addressed this issue allowing
Farmers to harvest faster and more
safely carrot Harvesters are equipped
with systems that securely grip the
carrots and gently pull them from the
ground at the same time the machine can
remove soil and cut off the plant tops
ensuring a clean and tidy Harvest these
machines are particularly effective in
large- scale operations reducing product
loss and ensuring that the quality of
the carrots remains intact during the
harvesting both types of Harvesters have
made significant contributions to the
mechanization of Agriculture
particularly in large-scale farming
operations with the support of advanced
technology farmers can increase
productivity optimize costs and meet the
growing Global demand for food
Additionally the use of modern machinery
helps reduce the environmental impa
impact by using less Fuel and lowering
greenhouse gas emissions
[Music]
[Applause]
in conclusion potato and carot
Harvesters have reshaped the way crops
are cultivated and harvested bringing
substantial benefits to Modern
agriculture these machines play a key
role in boosting efficiency and
sustainability in the farming industry
meeting Global food production
challenges
[Music]
the onion Harvester has brought about a
revolution in global agriculture helping
Farmers optimize the harvesting process
and increase labor
productivity before Moder Machinery
onion harvesting was a labor intensive
and timec consuming task requiring many
workers to dig each bulb from the ground
this Not only was costly but also
reduced production efficiency modern
onion Harvesters automate the entire
process these machines can quickly and
efficiently dig onions from the soil
while cleaning the dirt off the bulbs
right in the field some models also
feature the ability to cut off the
unnecessary tops of the onions saving
even more time and effort in post post
Harvest processing thanks to these
features onion Harvesters have boosted
productivity reduced labor costs and
minimize product loss with the support
of Technology onion Harvesters have
played a vital role in transforming
agriculture from traditional methods to
large-scale production contributing to
the sustainable development of the
agricultural
[Music]
industry almonds one of the most popular
and economically valuable nuts worldwide
once posed a significant challenge for
farmers during Harvest time before
Modern Machinery Farmers had to shake
the trees manually or use primitive
tools to knock almonds from the trees a
process that was timec consuming labor
intensive and inefficient almond
harvesting machines have completely
transformed this process these machines
typically feature mechanical arms
capable of shaking the tree trunks
vigorously causing the almonds to fall
to the ground quickly and uniformly
afterward a suction and collection
system cleans and gathers the almonds
automatically this not only speeds up
the Harvest but also ensures the nuts
remain intact and undamaged the use of
almond harvesting machines significantly
reduces labor costs accelerates the
harvesting process and optimizes overall
production additionally machines ensure
better quality almonds compared to
manual methods thus enhancing the
product's market value on a global scale
[Music]
olives crucial in the production of
olive oil were traditionally harvested
by hand farmers use sticks to knock the
olives from the trees and manually
collected them from the ground this
method was not only laborious but also
damaged the trees and fruit leading to
lower quality olive oil oil modern Olive
harvesting machines have changed the
game entirely with automated vibrating
arms the machines can gently shake the
olives from the trees without damaging
them the olives are collected on
Conveyor Systems and large Nets beneath
the trees ensuring a continuous and
efficient harvesting process the
Precision of olive harvesting machines
minimizes damage to the trees and fruit
improving the quality of the olive oil
moreover automating the process boosts
production capacity reduces labor costs
and meets the growing Global demand for
olive oil
[Music]
grape harvesting particularly for
premium wine grapes requires a high
level of care to avoid damaging the
fruit traditionally grapes were
harvested by hand to ensure the bunches
remained intact a method that required a
significant amount of time and labor
modern grape Harvesters have optimized
this
process these machines are designed with
gentle shaking mechanisms to harvest
only ripe grapes without damaging the
vines or fruit many machines also come
equipped with systems to clean and sort
the grapes directly in the field
removing impurities and collecting only
the highest quality fruit with the
Precision of Technology grape Harvesters
not only increase productivity but also
ensure the grapes quality is maintained
especially for premium wine production
automation helps Farmers save time and
labor costs while boosting the economic
value of their grapes on International
Market
[Music]
[Applause]
markets as we've seen today modern
agricultural machines are reshaping the
way we grow and harvest our food from
reducing labor to increasing efficiency
these technological advancements are
helping Farmers meet the growing demands
of the global population if you're
passionate about about the future of
farming be sure to subscribe to Modern
Agri machines and stay updated on the
latest Innovations in agricultural
technology thank you for watching and
see you in the next video